bonjour à tous donc je m'appelle ludovic
bellinguer je travaille au sein du
centre de carrière du nid la salle où
j'accompagne au quotidien les élèves
ingénieurs dont la construction de leur
projet professionnel
donc avant de faire ce métier pendant
quelques années j'ai été recruteur dans
plusieurs entreprises donc à paris lille
et lyon
alors les métiers du recrutement sont un
métier qui qui sont extraordinaires
surtout pour des français en fait c'est
le seul métier où vous êtes payé pour
critiquer à longueur de journée les
personnes que vous rencontrez alors que
les français le font habituellement
gratuitement alors au delà de la
plaisanterie ce qui m'a vraiment
beaucoup plus dans les métiers du
recrutement
c'est cette capacité a rencontré très
régulièrement des personnes tous les
jours à vrai dire quotidiennement et
pouvoir discuter avec eux de leur
parcours de leurs motivations et
aujourd'hui j'ai construit ce tedx à
partir de ces quelques milliers d'
entretiens que j'ai réalisé tout au long
de ma carrière
alors qu'est ce que j'ai retenu
finalement de ces milliers d'entretien
alors j'ai retenu finalement une chose
une chose importante
et oui un bol en fait je vais vous
expliquer finalement ce que je retiens
de ces milliers d'entretien c'est une
méthode une méthode infaillible pour
avoir du bol savoir comment à coup sûr
avoir de la chance
en fait lorsque j'étais recruteurs
j'avais cette opportunité donc comme je
le raconte et de rencontrer des milliers
de candidats et j'ai eu la chance de
rencontrer des candidats avec des
parcours extraordinaire c'est à dire des
personnes qui avaient eu la chance
d'entreprendre des personnes qui avaient
pris des responsabilités soit au niveau
professionnel soit associatif soit à
travers des expériences de vie où vivre
des épreuves et quand vous êtes
recruteurs en tout cas c'était mon cas
systématiquement quand je rencontre s
je rencontrais ce type de candidat je
leur posais cette question à savoir
comment on fait ça comment on fait pour
à 19 ans à 20 ans à 25 ans avoir cette
opportunité de prendre ce type de
responsabilité d'intégrer cette
entreprise prestigieuse d'aller à
l'étranger etc etc et bien dans 99% des
cas mais candidat me répondait bas j'ai
eu du bol alors quand vous êtes
recruteur vous pouvez pas vous limiter à
ce type de réponse vous êtes obligés de
creuser et donc moi généralement je
creuse et en mode ça veut dire quoi
avoir de la chance ça veut dire que vous
êtes réveillé un matin et vous aviez un
contrat de travail qu'ils attendaient au
pied du lit alors vous êtes sortis dans
la rue vous avez rencontré un associatif
et vous amener à l'autre bout du monde
ah non non pas du tout pas du tout en
fait
dans cadre de mes études ou dans le
cadre de ma formation dans le cadre
associatif
j'ai eu l'opportunité de rencontrer des
personnes dans le cadre d'une conférence
et de leur poser des questions et en
fait
de fil en aiguille en discutant avec ces
personnes eh bien on a tissé des liens
et puis on a réussi à avoir j'ai réussi
en tout cas avoir ce type d'opportunité
alors vous l'aurez deviné premier la
première leçon que j'ai envie finalement
de vous passer à travers ce tedx c'est
de ne jamais refuser la rencontre plus
vous rencontrerai du monde tout au long
de votre carrière de votre vie plus vous
aurez de la chance rencontrer du monde
c'est bien mais c'est pas suffisant
c'est pas suffisant et sa gelée a pris
dans le cadre de mon parcours a uni la
salle à force d'accompagner de jeunes
ingénieurs dans la construction de leur
projet professionnel
en fait que j'ai ce que j'ai noté c'est
ce que j'appelle du fait de pélata alors
les faits pelle à tarte qu'est ce que
c'est c'est pour illustrer le fait que
parfois il est compliqué pour quelqu'un
d' expliquer en quelques mots une
expérience souvenez vous de noël dernier
vous étiez en train de fêter le
réveillon en famille
et vous avez votre grand-mère qui
découpe sept juges de noël avec sa pelle
à tarte et elle vous pose la question
fatidique à savoir si vous êtes élève
ingénieur par exemple a uni la salle au
fait dans ton école qu'est ce qu'on fait
ou alors quand vous êtes en poste
tiens au fait dans ton métier qu'est ce
qu'on fait là généralement vous allez la
regarder avec des yeux ronds et vous
allez commencer à balancer des mots-clés
écoute m'a mis dans mon post
enfin dans mon école par exemple a uni
la salle agriculture géologie
alimentation et santé gestion projet
abreuvoir des projets d'études de stage
et vous allez va lancer comme ça des
mots clés pendant quelques minutes 3 4
minutes et vous d'un instant votre grand
mère va pour regarder avec des yeux
ronds et sa pelle à tarte dans les mains
et vous dire ça a l'air super
intéressant
sauf que leur a rien compris voudrait
que quand vous allez rencontrer du monde
quand vous allez échanger avec des
professionnels des associatifs peu
importe quand vous leur demanderai d'
expliquer en quelques mots ce qu'ils
font ça va être un exercice qui va être
très compliqué pour et voilà pourquoi au
delà de rencontrer du monde
il faut savoir leur poser les bonnes
questions moi ce que je vous conseille
de faire c'est de poser trois à quatre
niveaux de questions le premier niveau
de questions il est là pour lutter
contre l'effet pas la tarte à savoir ces
fameux mots clés et bien qu'à chaque
fois qu'un professionnel va utiliser un
mot clé pour vous expliquer son métier
rebondissez dessus demandez lui un
exemple tu me dis que tu gères des
projets d'optimisation de la nutrition
animale en réfléchissant à leur
abreuvoirs et bien comment on fait ça
comment on fait ça concrètement quelles
sont les étapes
quels sont les outils qu'on utilise à
qui on travaille au quotidien pour faire
ça ce que je veux c'est qu'à chaque fois
que vous rencontriez quelqu'un à travers
ces questions vous puissiez sortir de
cette conversation en ayant la vision la
plus claire et la plus précise possible
de ce qui vous ai décrit ce premier
niveau de questions il n'est pas
suffisant derrière il faut s'intéresser
à donc aux cadres avec qui on travaille
sur ce type d'expérience de projets
finalement il faut s'inquiéter de
comment s'organisent les équipes avec
qui on travaille
comment quels sont les profils des
personnes donc sur ces projets qui ce
qu'on rencontre
comment est ce qu'on est comment ce
qu'on intègre ses équipes quand ce qu'on
y évoluent comment est-ce qu'on est
évaluée voudrais que dans votre vie
finalement le plus dur ça peut être
d'entreprendre des projets le plus
compliqué c'est d entreprendre avec des
personnes qu'on apprécie en qui on se
reconnaît qu'ils soient inspirante
c'est pour ça qu'un troisième niveau de
questions est vraiment essentiel pour
avoir ce type de déclic à savoir vous
pourrez demander à votre interlocuteur
ok j'ai bien compris ce que tu fais j'ai
bien compris les équipes avec lesquelles
tu travailles
mais toi qu'est ce qui te plaît dans ce
que tu fais
quitte à mu qu'est ce qui te permet de
s'épanouir et puis ensuite poser la
question inverse la question inverse
tant qu est ce qui compliquait qu'est ce
qui est difficile dans ce type
d'expérience et c'est là où vous verrez
que la réponse de votre interlocuteur
vont être très importantes
c'est là vous aurez déclic c'est là où
vous allez voir que finalement vous
allez vous reconnaître ou pas dans le
propos de vos interlocuteurs et parfois
vous dire ce qui est en train de me
raconter cette personne c'est exactement
ce que j'ai envie de faire c'est ça qui
m'inspire ou parfois vous agirez par
élimination c'est là que vous dirai lui
il s'épanouit à faire ça mais moi c'est
pas mon truc
si jamais vous avez un déclic positif il
ya un dernier niveau de questions à
poser à savoir ce que tu me racontes
ça me plaît beaucoup ça valide vraiment
tous les a priori positif que j'avais
sur ton expérience qu'elles seraient tes
conseils si j'ai envie de faire la même
chose et là vous verrez des personnes
qui vont vous partagez de précieux
conseils pour vous aider à avancer pour
vous aider à avoir du développement
personnel alors rencontrer du monde
ça permet d'avoir du bol leur poser des
questions ça augmente vos chances
voilà pourquoi je vous encourage à
rencontrer du monde et à leur poser des
questions mais il ya quand même quelques
pièges à éviter
en fait le premier piège auquel vous
serez confrontés c'est d'être croyant
mais pas pratiquants c'est à dire que
vous avez vous dire bah tiens rencontrer
du monde je suis persuadé que finalement
ça peut être utile mais vous le ferez
pas parfois par part a priori parce que
les personnes qui vont se présenter à
vous voilà donc pas là bas ni peut-être
on pas les bons à biron pas le bon
raisonnement vous reconnaîtrai pas
facilement toujours dans toutes les
personnes que vous rencontrerez et bien
je vous encourage à ne jamais refuser
les changes
même si les personnes ne vous inspire
pas forcément confiance au premier abord
fait cet exercice alors vous verrez que
dans 90% des cas
vos a priori seront validées mais dans
10 % des cas vous aurez une belle
surprise et une belle rencontre est une
opportunité d'évoluer il ya un deuxième
piège qu'il faut éviter c'est l'illusion
des réseaux sociaux
c'est vrai que des outils comme facebook
linkedin instagram etc sont des outils
formidables pour créer du lien avoir des
contacts mais ça ne remplacera jamais la
pertinence et la qualité d'un échange en
face à face dans la vraie vie
voilà pourquoi il faut pas céder à cette
tentation de mesurer l'étendue de son
réseau et ses rencontres à un nombre de
clics à un nombre de partage etc ne
refusait jamais les changes
c'est d'ailleurs mon dernier conseil ne
refusait jamais les chances parce que
vous aller solliciter les gens mais des
gens vont vous sollicitez est bien
accepté de répondre à leurs questions
accepté de témoigner parce que le
témoignage
c'est un outil de développement
personnel qui est formidable en
expliquant votre expérience
et bien vous allez la ré apprendre vous
allez la réinterpréter vous allez la
réanalyse réanalyser et ça c'est
extrêmement précieux d'ailleurs tous les
conseils que je viens de vous donner
sont très orienté professionnel parce
que c'est mon quotidien
mais à vrai dire ça marche pour tout ça
marche pour l'associatif ça marche pour
plein de projets que vous avez dans
votre vie professionnelle et personnelle
donc ne refusait jamais ça d'ailleurs ce
que je vous encourage à faire c'est tout
simplement
après cette conférence est bien de
profiter du cocktail pour mettre à
profit tous les conseils que l'on a pu
partager à travers cette conférence
parce que finalement le monde est à
portée de main mais il est aussi parfois
apporter deux coupes de champagne
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]